I've talked off and on about Jordan
Peterson who's quickly become known as a
sort of stunning and innovative
intellectual by pseudo-intellectuals and
anti intellectuals and anti sjw's and
I've basically characterized Jordan
Peterson as an anti SJW self-help
equivalent to Deepak Chopra with a
hidden twist of a Christian agenda and
I'm not going to recreate my entire
criticism of Peterson's rhetoric here
but the long and short of it is that he
became known for misstating what Canada
c16 bill would have done with regard to
transgender pronouns he used that
notoriety to publicly promote his again
Deepak Chopra like teachings which if
you want a critique you're told you're
either miss stating Peterson's
statements or you just don't understand
what Peterson is saying and he's grown
this massive income for himself on the
basis of appealing to this anti SJW
crowd so what I want to do today is look
at a specific video that was posted on
our subreddit that goes to an example of
the Hidden Kristin a Christian agenda
that many people just don't see or know
about Jordan Peterson he recently
debated friend of the show Matt
Dillahunty who I've interviewed before
and at a certain point during the debate
Peterson makes the ridiculous claim
which is that even people who say they
are atheists actually do believe in God
deep down maybe so deep down that they
don't even know it because if they were
actually atheists they wouldn't have a
moral compass and might be mass
murderers because you can't actually
have that moral compass without
accepting religion in some way maybe I'm
misunderstanding or Mis stating what
Peterson said I'm sure his followers
will say that so let's take a look at
the video yeah I'm trying to four years
I have this thing going where people
would say oh and this is kind of what
we're getting at from a different angle
I would say they would be afraid of what
we would lose if we lost religion and I
basically said demonstrate to me any
benefit oh you'd lose art and poetry and
drama and narrative library are there
are there no godless artists and poets
there are artists and poets who think
they're godless
so we might have crossed over into a
problem area yeah III don't actually I
can't draw for crap although I do draw
during the show but one of the
individuals who came to the show the
other night handed me something that she
had spent a great deal of time drawing
she's a wonderful artist I'm very
grateful to get it and you know while I
pretend to read minds on stage I
constantly acknowledge that I can't
actually read minds so I can't tell you
whether or not she actually believes in
a God but I can tell you that I actually
don't believe in a God and I could read
yeah coach for you huh buddy act like
you do that's what you did I say I'm off
the stage no now you're making a claim
okay
so I'm telling you I don't believe
there's a god and yeah your response to
that is I really do because I have a
moral sense but my moral sense is
utterly without any appeal to a god
explicitly or implicitly maybe the
that's not so obvious okay it's really
these are you regard sam harris as an
implicitly valuable entity as otherwise
you just throw them off the stage and
then the question is well just exactly
why is he an implicitly valuable entity
I don't see the physics of that I don't
think he's implicitly valuable in the
sense in the
first and foremost this is a hypothesis
that is unfalsifiable right the idea
that atheists believe in God so deep
down that even they don't know it you
can't test that and therefore it is not
of any effective value what's saying
what he's saying effectively is that it
might seem like you can be a good person
and have a moral compass and not believe
in God but in reality the reason you're
a good person is because you believe in
God even if you don't know about it and
that's what prevents you from being a
mass murderer or throwing sam harris off
of a stage how does this pass as
intellectual thought right this is an
example of the nonsense that he spews
wrapped up in being against social
justice warriors and transgender
pronouns and his audience just eats
everything up because they like the anti
sjw stuff and the amp the underlying
belief system and bias that's at play
here is atheists are secretly religious
and that's a really common thing among
true believers like Jordan Peterson
which is he can't really conceive of
someone having a belief system so
different than his so he finds an
explanation that deep down they must
believe in God because yeah he doesn't
see them committing mass murder or
throwing people off of stages I don't
know how any so-called non-religious
skeptic type can follow Jordan Peterson
and fall for his nonsense and I don't
get how the so-called free speech
warriors fall for it either since his
entire rise to fame was based on
misstating an issue of free speech that
c16 bill but I do want to congratulate
Jordan Peterson and I'm not doing this
sarcastically genuinely he's laughing
all that it all the way to the bank with
this stuff he has built a fantastic
business model on the basis of appealing
to these individuals and there is a ton
to be learned from Jordan Peterson but
it has nothing to be learned about his
there's it's not actually things to be
learned from his teachings it's about
how you can wrap yourself up in this
anti SJW free speech stuff and have
people accept you almost as a god-like
figure and give you their money
yeah when his patreon account numbers
were public he was making $60,000 per
month yeah I don't know where it's at
now but he also has his new book oh yeah
like the speaking tour is very lucrative
business model that's really is similar
to Deepak Chopra in that way as well who
also has a very very lucrative business
model and I mentioned that earlier but
he's also similar to the preacher dudes
that say donate donate donate and then
they buy themselves a private plane with
the money not that Peterson is buying
himself a private plane but it's the
idea of those guys who will sell you a
really well wrapped up package that
makes you say I'm gonna give them the
money and then you don't even really
know in the end what you're actually
given the money for so not surprising
but a lot of people unaware of the
underlying sort of Christian dogma of
Jordan Peterson will take a break and I
will talk next to Deborah SATs about
when markets don't work today's program
is sponsored in part by fruit or the
tour is a social forecasting game where
players come together and compete with
each other to predict future events you
open up the game on your phone or web
browser you'll see a whole range of
forecasts covering topics across the
board politics sports so much more you
wager on predictions about real world
events using fruit oars in game fake
currency and you earn more of this
currency every time you make a
prediction that comes true you can show
off your prediction skills to friends
improve your forecasting ability I'm
even on futur you can find my account by
clicking the link in the description if
you're watching this on YouTube and this
week on futur I posed the question will
robert molars trump russia investigation
end during this year during 2018 what do
you think place your bets and you can
sign up now at fruit or calm and start
making your forecasts on political
topics and so many other topics it's
free and it's available on both Android
and iOS as well as on web browsers
that's fut you you are calm